[Music]
[Applause]
it's coming up want to make way for sao
paulo antonio
the great football reporter for espn and
figured that
if we could lasso sell on a busy day and
talk to him about what exactly happened
in philadelphia and led to the parting
of doug peterson
and the philadelphia eagles sal thanks
for joining us on short notice
so was doug peterson fired
yes he was fired
and i think the chronology of it dan is
pretty simple you got to go back to last
year
he announced that mike grow his then
offensive coordinator
would be staying on and then when it
within a day later
he had to reverse direction and micro
was fired
along with some other assistant so i
think
it started there and then uh
it built up to the point where he said
in his
post-season press conference with howie
roseman that he wanted to have more
control
over picking coaches and perhaps players
and that was a signal and maybe it was a
signal that
we didn't really catch on to uh
enough but it was pretty clear and then
uh
there were some offensive assistants let
go he had this
group of uh of offensive coaches helping
him
morning wig scan gorilla gone gone and
he wanted to make press taylor his
offensive coordinator elevate him from
quarterback's coach
and uh the organization didn't agree
with that direction
and so they parted ways how attractive
is this eagles job
i don't know dan i don't know how
attractive it is listen there's one of
32 jobs right you know
somebody's going to take the job there's
going to be a lot of money involved
you don't turn down a nfl head coaching
job
but if you have seven openings you have
a lot of more
lucrative situations more attractive
situations let's start with the obvious
you're walking into a
home-cooked quarterback controversy
that's never good for a head coach two
your offensive line was absolutely
devastated by
injuries 13 different offensive line
combinations
most in the nfl it destroyed wence's
ability to play
and let's be truthful about it jalen
hurts didn't look good on the run either
constantly under pressure your general
manager
made a perhaps made a hundred and thirty
six million dollar mistake and kept his
job and so you walking into a situation
as a head coach
where you already have the gm picked for
you
you have two quarterbacks one of whom
had one of the worst seasons in nfl
history certainly in franchise history
and so your first question has to be to
jeffrey lurie what are we doing at
quarterback
and he says back to you right there and
he says can you fix carson wentz and you
say oh
oh oh time out the decision to keep
carson wentz is an organizational
decision
so what's the decision by the
organization are we keeping him
are we trying to move him are we
shopping him
if we're keeping him if you're telling
me my job is to fix carson wentz
then that's a completely different
conversation
do you think doug peterson's happy he's
out of there
oh oh you know i know doug well
doug is a really centered grounded
nice guy i've been covering the league
going back to 1988 he's my favorite guy
i've ever had to cover
favorite easy bar none is available
uh he is truthful
he's a solid family guy
he's about making sure his players are
taken care of
and he's a really easy guy to talk to
and get along with
and i think doug is about right now in
fact i talked to someone close to him
yesterday dan
doug is right now about taking some time
letting the air out of the pressure a
little bit
go back to his home in jupiter florida
with his wife jeannie
and his beautiful family they're very
faith-based faith-centered
they'll talk about it they'll pray about
it
and then they'll decide what to do so
i think he's relieved that he doesn't
have to deal with what he had
listen you got to remember he started
the season
in august with covet 19. you remember
that right
he survived the deadliest disease known
to man in a hundred years
and so maybe he's thinking okay
i gotta just be mindful of where i
am in life i brought a super bowl title
to a city that never had one
i have a beautiful family i've made a
lot of money
let's just take a breath and see where
we are
we're talking to sao paolo antonio of
the mothership yeah just trying to
figure this out when
you start to look at they got some older
players they missed on some draft
picks the quarterbacking situation there
there's other openings that feel like
they're far more advantageous for
somebody if they're going to take their
first nfl job that they would go into
that the expectation level is still high
in philadelphia
a little bit yeah yeah yeah
so i i but but would they let him go if
they didn't already have a plan in place
because normally
you're if you make a decision like this
you have a pretty good idea of what
you're going to do
to follow up this decision yeah and this
is something that you and i talked about
last week
i was against firing doug peterson and
i'm still against it
and i said to you last week i want to
know what the plan is
right you say you want a revolution let
me know what the plan is
so um right now i feel like
they're interested in interviewing mike
kafka the quarterbacks coach
under andy reading kansas city they
tried to make kafka
a candidate for offensive coordinator
last year and were buffed by
big red i think they will look at eric
the enemy and will definitely
interview him i think they will have a
sincere
authentic interest in interviewing deuce
daily their running backs coach
and assistant head coach and they should
news is really well liked in the locker
room
and it's deuces time for sure hundred
percent
and they should look at him i know
they're interested in brian dabal
dabal is a bob lamont client
so is howie roseman as everybody has
well documented lamont likes to have the
gm
and the coach in the same place problem
is
i think the jets and the chargers both
have serious interest in day ball and
dave all has
serious interest in those teams which
goes back to your point
those two places may be more luke maybe
more attractive
than philly because of herbert and the
second overall pick
i'll leave you with this do we still
know exactly what happened with the nate
sedfeld decision in when he was going to
play
and whose call it was because i i'm
still fascinated by that and it feels
like that locker room may have gotten
fractured
because of this dan
to quote bill belichick i'm on to
cincinnati
great to talk to you south thanks for
joining us
sao palantonio the mothership